[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
heute mit niedrigen sie riet guten abend
ihnen alle norbert könig hat gleich das
wichtigste vom sport ja ich bin genannt
nach dem abzug russischer truppen sind
schockierende kriegsbilder aufgetaucht
und damit beginnt unser überblick
weltweites entsetzen nach mutmasslichen
gräueltaten der russischen armee
verlangt die bundesregierung aufklärung
spannende parlamentswahl in ungarn ein
breites oppositionsbündnis fordert
premier orban heraus
und spitzenspiel in der
frauen-bundesliga im dauerduell
deklassiert wolfsburg die bayern mit
sechs zu null
entsetzliche kriegsbilder aus einem
vorort von kiew erschüttern nicht nur
die internationale politik zu sehen
zahlreiche leichen offenbar vom
russischen militär hingerichtete
zivilisten manche von ihnen gefesselt
die bilder so brutal dass es weltweit
ein echo des entsetzens gibt
bundeskanzler scholz spricht von
kriegsverbrechen und kündigt neue
sanktionen an volker dutschek und
christian volk
es sind bilder von chaos und leid
gepanzerte fahrzeuge in butter
ineinander verkeilt russische
ukrainische jetzt da die russen den ort
nördlich von kia verlassen haben kehrt
die bevölkerung zurück und sieht bilder
die man kaum aushalten kann tote mitten
auf der straße männer frauen kinder die
meisten sollen zivilisten seien bisher
weiß man nicht viel darüber wie sie zu
tode kam einige sollen gefesselt gewesen
sein sagen ukrainische
regierungsvertreter die nationalpolizei
schiebt autos von der straße sie
vermutet überall minen und sprengfallen
auch an den leichnam wieder getöteten
einwohner des entsetzten weltweit für
die opfer ein namenloses massengrab die
staatsanwaltschaft spricht am abend von
410 toten in butter und den umliegenden
dörfern die deutsche bundesregierung
will dass die verantwortlichen zur
rechenschaft gezogen werden die
ermordung von zivilisten ist ein
kriegsverbrechen
diese verbrechen der russischen
streitkräfte müssen wir schonungslos
aufklären ich verlange dass
internationale organisationen die das
internationale komitee vom roten kreuz
zugang erhalten zu diesen gebieten und
die gräueltaten dokumentieren die
ukrainische regierung nennt es
völkermord verlangt neue schärfere
sanktionen gegen russland
in der ukraine haben wir mehr als 100
nationalitäten hier geht es um die
zerstörung und vernichtung all dieser
nationalitäten
das verteidigungsministerium in moskau
bezeichnet die videos als fälschung die
russischen truppen hätten die vororte
kias schon am mittwoch verlassen und
erst jetzt vier tage später würde dieses
gefälschte bildmaterial auftauchen im
bild sein nur schauspieler zu sehen
behauptet moskau
wir gehen nach berlin zuschlag unter
labbadia unterlag kanzler scholz hat auf
die gräueltaten sehr schnell sehr direkt
reagiert was könnte das bedeuten
ja das könnte bedeuten dass da auch für
ihn eine rote linie überschritten
gewesen ist beim anschauen dieser bilder
die frage ist allerdings was folgt
daraus vizekanzler habeck und
außenministerin berbalk haben schon
angekündigt dass jetzt über schärfere
sanktionen geredet werden muss auch
verteidigungsministerin lambrecht hat
gesagt im europäischen verbund müsse man
jetzt zum beispiel über einen gasstopp
diskutieren aber olaf scholz selbst ist
eben in seinem statement da etwas
ungenauer geblieben er hat gesagt man
werde jetzt mit den europäischen
partnern weitere maßnahmen besprechen
und die folgen würde putin auch spüren
ob dazu auch das um in deutschland
umstrittene energie embargo gehört dass
es nicht klar da hat sich die
bundesregierung ja bisher gegen gesperrt
ob sie angesichts dieser bilder und das
sicherlich steigenden drucks aus europa
dabei bleiben kann das wird sich zeigen
danke und alar mehr zum thema auch nach
uns mit dir in berlin direkte unter
anderem mit einem robert habeck
interview vielen dank jetzt zur
spannenden parlamentswahl nach ungarn es
geht auch um die politische zukunft des
amtsinhabers
ministerpräsident orban regiert
ununterbrochen seit fünf jahren das land
in seiner amtszeit wurde die
unabhängigkeit der medien und der justiz
massiv eingeschränkt ihm gegenüber ein
breites oppositionsbündnis von rechts
bis links vereint in dem ziel orban
abzuwählen ihr spitzenkandidat ist peter
markise über die richtungswahl jetzt
wolf christian ulrich
ministerpräsident viktor orban gab seine
stimme heute früh in budapest ab ich
erwarte einen großen sieg das ist das
was dieses land braucht der kontinent im
system orban ist alles auf diesen
grossen sieg ausgerichtet presse
wirtschaft machtapparat russlands krieg
wurde für putin partner orban im
wahlkampf zum problem er versucht sich
zwischen ost und west zu positionieren
seine wähler goutieren das
ich bin zwar nicht komplett zufrieden
mit der regierung aber ich finde dass in
der aktuellen situation orbáns fidesz
partei besser ist
die sechs wichtigsten
oppositionsparteien treten bei dieser
wahl gemeinsam an um eine chance gegen
orban zu haben
ich möchte ein ungarn wo die jungen
leute auch bleiben können arbeit finden
und zumindest annähernd gehälter auf
westlichem niveau bekommen
spitzenkandidat peter matkey sei ein
konservativer wirtschaftswissenschaftler
kämpft gegen die korruption des urban
systems außerdem ist die opposition klar
pro eu markise gab heute morgen in
seinem südungarischen heimatort die
stimme ab
wir kämpfen für demokratie und anstand
für die unabhängigkeit der justiz und
für die rechtsstaatlichkeit in ungarn
in budapest drängten heute vormittag
viele menschen in die wahllokale
doch insgesamt liegt die wahlbeteiligung
etwas niedriger als vor vier jahren mit
verlässlichen ergebnissen wird erst am
späteren abend gerechnet
dann jetzt live nach budapest zu britta
hilpert britta wonach sich aktuell aus
ja sicher ist schon mal dass diese etwas
niedrigere wahlbeteiligung kein plus ist
für die opposition das hätte hier
genutzt wenn wir leute zur wahl gegangen
sind und es gibt auch weitere kleinere
hinweise darauf dass es vielleicht für
arbeit wieder erreicht es ist noch
überhaupt nicht verlässlich in ungarn
gibt es keine exit polls es gibt keine
befragung nach denen wahllokal aber hier
im pressesaal macht das schon die runde
dass es wohl für opfern gerade noch
gereicht hat vielleicht nicht mit einer
verfassungsändernden zweidrittelmehrheit
und das ehrlich gesagt wäre schon eine
sensation denn orban hat die jahre an
der regierung natürlich auch dazu
genutzt das wahlrecht zu seinen gunsten
zu ändern so dass seine partei immer
bevorteilt wird so ist es ihm gelungen
beim letzten mal mit rund 49 prozent der
stimmen eine zweidrittelmehrheit im
parlament zu erringen es wäre also für
die opposition schon ein erfolg wenn sie
wenigstens diese zweidrittelmehrheit von
fidesz brechen könnte aber das ist noch
nicht klar ob das der opposition
gelungen ist auch noch nicht klar ob es
wirklich gereicht hat auch für orban
denn ihr wollt christian tore schon
sagte verlässliche ergebnisse gibt es
erst in einigen stunden man darf
gespannt sein danke live aus guter pass
war dass britta hilpert gewählt wird
auch im nachbarland serbien die
stimmberechtigten sind aufgerufen das
parlament und den präsidenten zu wählen
dabei wird die wiederwahl des
amtierenden nationalisten vucic erwartet
wichtigster herausforderer der frühere
militärchef pohlers der von der
proeuropäischen opposition unterstützt
wird
sehr umstritten mit dem heutigen tag
fallen fast überall in deutschland die
korona schutzmaßnahmen außer in
krankenhäusern und öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln braucht keine masken
beziehungsweise drei oder zwei regeln
mehr allerdings können betriebe von
ihrem hausrecht gebrauch machen und
selber bestimmen aus bayern petra
neubauer
letzte lagebesprechung im
trachtengeschäft von maria reiter in
rosenheim heute ist verkaufsoffener
sonntag und das ohne corona
beschränkungen erst einmal
gutes gefühl grundsätzlich ist es für
uns natürlich eine erleichterung wenn
man nicht acht stunden oder länger
permanent die maske tragen müssen
dennoch wolle man hier flexibel
reagieren wenn gewünscht mit maske
bedienen die kunden an diesem ersten tag
gespalten ich werde die nächste zeit so
aufsetzen wie ich sie vorher erwartet
habe und von uns gewesen ich denke jetzt
ist der zeitpunkt an dem sein was das
risiko überschaubar ist dabei liegt die
inzidenz in rosenheim noch immer bei
rund 2000 die impfquote bei nur 66
prozent
infektiologen warnen viele menschen
denken nun mit aufhebung der masken
pflicht ist die pandemie vorbei
und dem ist nicht so ich halte es für
irreführend jetzt auch öffentlich dinge
sehr sehr stark zu lockern eine masken
pflicht bei hausrecht anordnen das
wollen laut einer umfrage nur etwa zwölf
prozent der bayerischen händler auch im
ausstellungszentrum lokschuppen hält man
davon trotz so vieler besucher heute
nichts
reagieren die leute ungehalten drauf wir
stellen es den leuten frei unsere
besucher machen es ungefähr halbe-halbe
gerade viel eigenverantwortung ist also
gefragt offen bleibt allerdings ob das
funktioniert
so jetzt geht es hier bei uns sportlich
weiter und norbert könig übernimmt ja
mit einem herben dämpfer für den fc
bayern und zwar für die frauen denn in
der bundesliga jubeln heute die
wolfsburgerinnen nach dem 6 zu 0 gegen
den amtierenden meister aus münchen hat
der vfl wolfsburg drei spiele vor
schluss vier punkte vorsprung und damit
beste chancen auf den siebten deutschen
meistertitel
den anfang der wolfsburger tor jährige
macht svenja huth bereits nach acht
minuten nach dem führungstreffer der
gastgeberinnen ist das spiel für eine
knappe halbe stunde offen doch noch vor
der pause erhöhen erste wedemeyer und
dann tabea wasmuth zum 3 0 für die
tabellenführer rinnen die münchnerinnen
haben auch in der zweiten hälfte dem
wolfsburger tor drang nichts
entgegenzusetzen im gegenteil alexandra
popp mit dem 4 0 gegen die
titelverteidigerinnen die nach dem
champions league aus gegen paris st
germain und vielen corona bedingten
ausfällen sehr müde wirken und es kommt
noch schlimmer lena oberdorf und dann
noch in der nachspielzeit eva perón
sorgen für den 6 0 endstand und damit
für eine mehr als deutliche
vorentscheidung im kampf um die deutsche
meisterschaft
die wolfsburger männer haben heute
nichts zu feiern der fc augsburg gewinnt
im ersten sonntagsspiel klar mit 3 zu 0
und hat jetzt 3 punkte vorsprung auf die
abstiegsränge nach dem wechselfehler des
fc bayern beim sc freiburg die männer
haben die verantwortlichen der
breisgauer noch nicht über einen
einspruch entschieden der bis morgen
nachmittag eingelegt werden müsste die
bayern hatten gestern für ein paar
sekunden mit zwölf spielern auf dem
platz gestanden und spannendes finale
nach 273 kilometern bei der flandern
rundfahrt im zielsprint holt sich der
niederländer macho van de pol zum
zweiten mal den sieg beim frühjahrs
klassiker in belgien vor seinem
landsmann dylan van baalen ärger dagegen
bei tour-de-france-sieger tadday
boccaccio der sich verpokert und am ende
nur vierter wird
bei so einem kann man sagen nur vierter
viele norbert wir werfen noch schnellen
blick aufs wetter und das geht so im
norden kräftiger regen im osten und im
bergland teils mit schnee vermischt dazu
starker südwestwind mit schweren
sturmböen im süden trocken und sonnige
abschnitte vier bis zehn grad auch in
den nächsten tagen nass und windig
allerdings wird es dann wieder ein
bisschen milder
wir empfehlen auch das heute journal mit
christian sievers 21 uhr 45 geht's los
wir fangen heute 19 team sind morgen
wieder für sie da schönen dank fürs
zuschauen einen schönen sonntagabend